today on the matt walsh show we will
discuss the latest example proving that
there is a full-fledged war on childhood
innocence in our culture also
senile biden continues screaming
dementedly into cameras the seattle
teachers union prepares to go on strike
the mayor of chicago recoils in horror
as busloads of illegal immigrants show
up in her city and men's health magazine
declares that heterosexuality is a
shameful offensive disgusting fetish all
of that and more today on the matt walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
regardless of what the administration
defines as a recession americans are
worried that's the fact food and gas
prices are higher than i've ever seen in
my lifetime which is why i'm so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers while grocery store meat
prices continue to rise good rancher's
inflation-proof model locks you in on
the price that you subscribe to on the
day that you subscribe for the life of
your subscription it does not change
plus you can pause your subscription for
up to 90 days or cancel anytime you want
but trust me you won't want to good
rancher ships 100 american meat born
raised and harvested in the u.s right to
your door all of their beef is prime or
upper choice the two highest grades
available superior steakhouse quality
good ranchers not only supports american
agriculture they're also big fans of the
daily wire they sponsor all of our shows
that's good enough reason i think to go
check them out and the other reason is
that the food is just delicious so go to
goodranchers.com walsh and use codewall
should check out
you'll get 30 off plus free shipping you
can subscribe to lock in your price and
recession proof your meets for life you
got to do that right now that's
goodranchers.comwalsh and use codewalsh
at checkout
well it was a very gender stereotypical
weekend in my family much like every
other weekend i suppose but even more so
this time because i took my sons for a
boys trip and my wife took the girls for
a girls trip and the girls apparently
spent the long weekend eating at nice
restaurants and shopping and they even
on saturday dressed up real fancy-like
and went to a tea time which is
something that exists in the modern
united states evidently i had no idea
for our part uh you know the boys went
to a lake house in kentucky now
originally i mentioned on the show i
wanted to rent a dilapidated shack in
the woods that i found on airbnb
but my wife was concerned about the
serial killer factor we went back and
forth about it ultimately
unsurprisingly she won that argument so
we settled on the lake house instead and
we spent our time kayaking and fishing
and hiking and collecting interesting
rocks and bones that we found along the
shoreline and so on we ate hot dogs that
we cooked over a fire we didn't bathe of
course the whole weekend
at night we watched westerns we had a
lot of interesting conversations too
many of them centered around dinosaurs
my boys are finally going through a
dinosaur phase and i'm grateful for that
because i love dinosaurs and for years i
haven't had anyone to talk to about them
and that finally is changing it was a
good time all told
and the sort of childhood experience
that i want the boys to remember as they
get older most importantly i want them
to actually have
a childhood my wife and i want that
desperately for all of our children and
we have organized much of our lives
around this goal because that's what you
have to do now as a parent if you want
your child to have a childhood you have
to be very intentional about it a fun
weekend is nice but these days parents
have to work
nearly constantly to protect and nurture
their children's childhoods
kids can't do it themselves and they
don't realize how precious it is anyway
that's not the kind of thing you realize
until it's gone and it's too late
the other thing kids don't realize and a
lot of parents unfortunately don't
realize either until it's also too late
is that we live in a culture which has
dedicated itself
to destroying childhood
so it requires the active protection and
preservation of us as parents because
there are so many forces actively
engaged in an effort to demolish it
our culture
sees the innocence of childhood as a
thing to be
exploited and eradicated
but the innocence of childhood is
childhood innocence is what makes it
childhood it's it's the thing that we
look back on fondly as adults and mourn
having lost
innocence is also what adds a sort of a
bittersweet tinge to every wholesome
moment that we have with our kids
because eve you know as parents we we
look at our kids and we know something
they don't know we know
that
this isn't going to last we know that
one day
they'll be jaded and weary just like us
and it hurts us to think about that but
it's the truth
yet if we aren't diligent
then the loss of innocence
happens much sooner than it should
and at a time when our kids aren't ready
for it
when i got home on monday night and uh
started the often
slightly or even extremely depressing
process of prepping for my show the
following day
the first thing that i saw
was this video highlighted by chris
ruffo and originally produced by lori
children's hospital now this is another
one of those materials which was
published by a children's hospital but
which you and i are not allowed to
notice and certainly not a lot to talk
about
lest we be terrorists
so terrorists we will be i guess because
uh here's the video
all right so you want to talk about
gender today yes
so what do you what is gender to you
like my birth parents said that i was a
girl but they made a mistake yeah us two
yeah right so your mommy and i we
assumed that you were a girl
but then when did you set a straight
well i was at least like five or six but
it started before that you kept sending
us signals right you'd say sometimes
i want to be a boy yeah sometimes i want
to be a girl something just doesn't seem
right here well it wasn't a girl or a
boy ah so what are you
non-binary right and how do you feel
about being non-binary
good your mom and i have tried our best
to support you and make that like a
something that's celebrated in our
household have you ever spoken to your
class
about your gender yeah what did you tell
it i told them my pronouns
and also my name and why are your
pronouns important to you
well
like it'd be like if i just i was like i
can't remember your name i'm just going
to call you susie wait what yeah that
wouldn't be so cool with it well if you
ever forget someone's name you can ask
them yeah if you forgot their name you
can ask them or if you don't know
somebody's pronouns you can ask them
right so asking is very important yeah
it represents you right yeah
like how did it feel to like be able to
share your story like really really
really good it felt really good
lord i hate these people i really do
the woman in that i i just i just
despise them
and everything they stand for i despise
it so much
and we're supposed to buy that as some
sort of organic
conversation
while the child is
obviously repeating what has been
rehearsed
now i watched that video
and i immediately think of my boys
running down the shoreline excitedly
picking up rocks they spend hours doing
this by the way i mean just like they
could spend hours picking up rocks
even though the child in in the video is
about the same age as my kids what she's
talking about rather being forced to
talk about you know the lines that she's
being coerced into repeating
are so far outside of the world
that my kids live in
they are 10
million miles away from all of that
they've never heard the phrase
non-binary they don't know what gender
identity is
they spend
zero percent of their time thinking
about pronouns
they don't think about sex either
because kids at that age shouldn't be
thinking about sex at all or anything
related to it
and they won't think about it or talk
about it unless the adults suggest it
no child thinks about any of this stuff
or wants to think about it
this has to be imposed from the outside
their their innocence is ripped away and
this
is put in its place
now
when uh when
whenever we talk about this uh the war
on childhood innocence we've talked
about many times and we've arrived at
the i think correct conclusion that much
of this is driven by the left's desire
to exploit
the ignorance of childhood
you know we see innocence
they see ignorance and and you know
ignorance and innocence go hand in hand
they're they're they're uh p's in a pod
as it were but that's that's what the
left homes in on the ignorance part of
that because then that means that this
is this is something they can exploit
much of what they profess as leftist is
so self-evidently absurd that they have
to recruit people at an age when they
lack the mental capacity to notice
absurdity or distinguish fantasy from
reality children are easy prey
and if they're brainwashed young enough
and in large enough numbers the entire
generation eventually becomes an
ideological army for the left
so that's that's part of the story and
that's the part of the story that we
talk about a lot
that's kind of the plan uh the plot
concocted and put into effect by
powerful people and institutions
but on an individual level
however
the war on innocence is also
largely a product of
just narcissistic adults
who self-absorption is like a black hole
that sucks everything into itself
so not all of them necessarily say to
themselves explicitly i'm going to
corrupt this child because it will help
my cause ideologically and politically
lots of them
are that intentional about it obviously
but in many other cases they barely even
see the child
they barely see anything at all
because whenever they look at anything
or anyone they only see themselves
reflected back
the girl in that video
gets sucked into this world by sheer
gravitational pull
now it's obvious there's a lot of
intentionality there too because the
mother has taken this
poor child
and put her on display
but even if she didn't
the girl hardly stands a chance with a
mother like that she was cursed with
this
self-obsessed egomaniac
now to to protect a child
and her innocence requires you to see
outside of yourself it requires you to
value something greater than yourself
it requires you to have the capacity for
sacrifice
for love
you know you see a child the innocence
of childhood and you say this is a
wonderful
joyful thing
that is good for a child and i'm going
to
not only let them have that innocence
but i'm going to protect it not for me
not because it's going to help me but
just for them for their own sake that's
it
but to say that to yourself to do that
requires it requires
love it requires you to see outside of
yourself and these people cannot do that
it is beyond their grasp
and so children are made to
pay the price
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know in a society rife with
anti-religious ideologies like the ones
we hear from the left on a daily basis
it can be incredibly challenging to
ground oneself in what we know to be
true and good to keep from descending
into distress frustration or even hatred
that's why i find god's peace every day
through prayer and meditation with hello
hallo
is the number one christian prayer app
in the us and the number one catholic
app catholic app in the entire world is
rooted in catholic tradition
but it's an amazing resource for any
christian looking to dive deeper into
their prayer life which is something we
should all be looking to do all the time
hallow has prayers and meditations to
guide you throughout your entire day
morning tonight and hallow is launching
it's exclusive um athlete prayers as
well you can join some of the best
christian athletes in the world like
brett favre for some motivational
inspirational meditations to help you
get off your lazy butt and get to the
gym or train for a race or sport or
whatever it is hello not only will help
your spiritual health but also your
physical health as well let hallow help
you find your peace and strength
throughout the day try it for three
months free at hallow.com matt walsh or
text pray to one eight five five nine
four four five six eight four that's
hello dot dot com slash matt walsh or
text pray to 1-855-944-5684
for three months free reclaim your peace
in this crazy world download hallow
today
all right so biden has uh passed fully
into his grumpy old man phase his grumpy
old man shouting phase which i guess
makes it sound
less sinister than it is biden is a
grumpy old
dementia riddled man
who also happens to be president and is
part of a system notice i didn't say
controls a system because he doesn't
control it but it's part of a system
that seeks to obliterate our fundamental
human rights and destroy our
civilization and uh eat our children
alive spiritually mentally and also in
many ways physically so anyway with that
specified uh biden was campaigning
yesterday when he launched into a rant
about big pharma
and made some rather
dubious claims listen
the last several decades many of us have
been trying to fix the problem
but for decades big pharma
tried to block giving lower drug prices
for those on medicare or anywhere else
for decades big pharma won year in year
out because they owned chunks of the
congress
because they had to help
like your senior senator ron johnson who
said
no
i want to say what he said
he said he opposed lowering drug costs
because it would result in punishing the
pharmaceutical industry
bless me father for i have sinned i mean
come on man
not this year we beat farmer this year
we beat farmer this year and it mattered
we're gonna change people's lives
we finally beat pharma
now medicare will have the power to
negotiate lower prescription drug prices
we can guarantee no senior
no senior will have to pay more than two
thousand dollars out of pocket for their
drugs for the entire year no matter
whether the bill is fifty thousand no
more than two thousand dollars
period
it almost seems like there's a jump cut
there or something where because he he
transitions so suddenly from the from
the come on man we beat pharma screaming
and pointing at the
at the camera
um
but putting putting that aside for a
second
listen to the claim that he's actually
making
you beat big pharma beat them
you i mean and you say we you mean like
the democrats right your your regime
well this is like this is like the
mcdonald's marketing team bragging that
they beat mcdonald's it doesn't even
it's not just that it's not correct
the claim doesn't make sense you're all
part of the same thing the same
institution the same mechanism
i mean you beat them
the democrat party and big pharma are
practically inseparable
entities the democrats are like the
marketing arm of big pharma
which i guess in some ways doesn't quite
work as an analogy because most
marketing departments though they wish
they did have the capacity in fact do
not have the capacity to literally force
people to use the product if they could
they would but they can't that's why
they market
but the democrats did exactly that
when they forced millions of americans
to use
big pharma's vaccine product so this is
how you beat big pharma by putting
billions of dollars into their pocket
that's how you beat them
that's how you defeat them
i mean if i if only i could be defeated
that way
so we defeated big pharma by putting
billions of dollars into their pocket
over the last few years
and when they're not forcing people to
use the product um they're funneling
millions of kids into big pharma's
clutches and getting them on puberty
blockers and hormones and all the rest
of it
in fact big pharma
and there are many examples that reveal
this to be the case but
of all the examples
big pharma
most convincingly proves
that everything the democrats say about
being
anti-corporation and they all they don't
like millionaires and bills proves all
that to be false
because of big pharma
this multi-billion dollar industry and
the democrats their entire machine just
funneling people into its
arms
it's a welcoming greedy arms
constantly
of course by the way you know it's i say
democrats and uh it's not like the
republicans are much better on this
front
they're really of the two parties
neither one of them
are doing much of anything to curtail
big pharma or to actually beat them
whatever exactly that would mean
and there are things that that that
could be done that you would think
there would be there could be some
actual bipartisan agreement about
obviously if the republicans make
serious efforts to stop big pharma from
shoving you know hormones and everything
into into children
if they do that which republicans really
haven't made any serious effort in that
on that front but we know democrats are
going to oppose that
but there are other things that could be
done
to actually regulate and control big
pharma and to help weaken their grasp on
the american public one of them like we
talked about before is banning direct to
consumer advertisements
that's a that that's something that
there's no immediately obvious reason
why you couldn't have bipartisan
agreement on that
it doesn't appear to be a partisan thing
but big pharma basically owns both
parties and that's why there is not
agreement on that
speaking of angry old man i wanted to
play this too by the way the lead singer
of dropkick murphy's which uh used to be
a punk band and now is just a bunch of
old dudes telling the party line
here he is uh this went viral
yesterday here he is at a concert
railing against conservatives let's
listen
if you were part of a union or work
across people who were allowed to build
a better life in the middle class in
america you
listen to us
[Applause]
because if you're out there buying those
hats these swizzlers are selling at that
fair i'm sorry kids i know there's kids
here
then you're part of the problem and i'll
tell you why because you're being duped
by the greatest swindler in the history
of the world you're being duped by a
bunch of grifters and billionaires
above you or your family they care about
their tax breaks and the money they can
put in their pocket
if you consider yourself a patriot and
you're spouting off that election
tonight
i will fight your ass outside if you
want to
wake the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
we're working class people
these people are the rich the
billionaires that they don't give us
[Applause]
thank you for listening
someone get grandpa's meds yeah i just i
love this don't you i love going to a
concert hoping to hear some music and
instead a 55 year old pudgy guy screams
msnbc talking points that's just that's
exactly what you're looking for when you
buy a
ticket for a concert first of all the
democrats are as we just discussed he's
here again
um
pretending the democrats are oh the
party of the working class
now they are the party of millionaires
and billionaires which is why nearly
every major corporation in the country
is run by leftists and has an overt
leftist agenda every single one so party
the working class that entire talking
point is out the window
you can still keep saying it but it
doesn't mean anything anymore second i
just think it's interesting these these
aging rock stars and a bit generous i
guess of a description for the dropkick
murphy guy to say he was ever a rock
star but whatever he he's he's aging
anyway uh these aging rock stars
you know they want to act like they're
still rebelling against the system
but they represent the system you know
they're raging for the system now
there may have been a time when it was
actually true that they were
rebelling against someone something i
suppose but now they now they're a part
of the ideology that owns the system
and you're left with
pathetic displays just like that
all right this is from the seattle times
it says more than a hundred seattle
educators gathered on labor day at
judkins park stapling and taping signs
to wooden tickets in preparation for a
potential strike
one sign read liberation through public
education
on tuesday seattle teachers will find
out if they have enough votes to
authorize a strike then it comes down to
whether the seattle education
association in seattle public schools
can strike a deal before wednesday which
is the expected first day of classes if
the impasse remains seattle could be the
second large k-12 school district in the
area to be mired in a strike the kent
school district was supposed to start
classes on august 25th
but a strike stretches on as the kent
education association demands more pay
smaller class sizes a more manageable
staff to student ratio in special
education and english language learner
programs as well as more staffing for
student mental health support
kent school district officials and the
teachers association met with a mediator
on labor day but still did not reach an
agreement um
there's also a video from this is a i
believe an elementary school teacher in
seattle
explaining why she supports going on
strike let's listen
my name is heather barker and i'm an
educator at stanislaw elementary
um and i voted yes for the strike
authorization vote and i did that
because i think that we need to have a
contract that shows us respect and shows
us respect as the experts that we are
that we know our children and we know
how to best
support them and to give them the
world-class education that we know that
they deserve
and that they can get here in seattle
public schools
we are fighting to ensure that we have
reasonable workloads so that we are
available to support our kids
we are fighting to make sure that we
have
a workable
special education
model to keep all of our kids safe
and to keep our staff safe we are
fighting to make sure that we have
access to the mental health care that
our kids need because we have a lot of
needs coming out of this pandemic
and we just need to be there to support
our kids and we need to have contract
language that lays that out for us so
that we know that we can be delivering
the best possible education and learning
experience for all of our kids
i'm standing with seattle education
association
yeah i bet you are i i mean i i'm so so
sick of public school teachers i really
am and yeah i'm gonna i i
yes
all of the qualifiers right that there
are there are exceptions there are still
some good ones i i know that because
i've met some good ones and i know that
they're
uh increasingly in you know it's like
they're working behind enemy lines i
have a lot of respect for that
um
so there are exceptions to what i'm
going to say now i've established the
exceptions so now i'm going to continue
in general i can't stand these people
they
i i don't think that there's any group
in america that hates working as much as
public school teachers do they they ab
they just hate it
they get like two months off a year they
get every single holiday off they get
nice breaks for
for they get a nice win
i was gonna say christmas break we don't
call it that right it's a win they get a
nice winter break they get a nice they
get a smaller spring but they still get
a spring break uh they get multiple
months in the summer oh well but we have
to we still have to prepare for classes
and we got to come in for teacher days
or whatever yeah you still get you get
multiple months in the summer basically
off no one else gets that
and then covet rolls around
schools are shut down for
over a year in some cases
and it's still it's still too much work
they're still complaining about the
workload now they go on strike
what what do you want exactly
do you think that being a teacher should
should require no work at all
and every time i i bring this up i'm
always told by oh no this is this is a
misconception the teachers get a lot of
time off no it's not
we can all see it we're not stupid they
shut down the schools for like
during
from out of 12 months
multiple months cumulative the schools
are shut down
so we can all see that
they get all this time off it's still
not enough
but even putting that aside
i'll tell you what really frustrates me
the most when i when i especially want
to hear stuff like this
from that teacher first of all it's it's
the pretending
that you're doing this for the kids
well this is really about providing the
best experience to the kids this is all
about the kids i want a
higher salary
for the kids
are you sharing your salary with the
kids
are you giving them uh like a cut are
they getting a commission
no at least have the honesty to admit
it's for you you want more money for
yourself
now on its own that's that's
understandable everybody wants more
money okay so just say that
that's what i would want you
you want to make a video explaining why
you're going on strike at least admit
i'm going on strike because because this
is an op this is a way we can hold the
kids hostage this is a power that we
have
okay we have control over kids
educations
and lots of parents depend on us as de
facto babysitters basically
and uh because they got to go to work
and they got to send the kids to school
and so this is power that we have and i
can use that power to get more money for
myself and so that's what i'm doing
because i want more money
i could respect the honesty at least if
you would just say that but when you
pretend that you want more benefits and
more time off and more luxuries and more
this and a greater salary for the kid's
sake
it insults our intelligence
and then also
you want to this is a common complaint
we hear from the public school teachers
that that the class sizes are too big
well you know what
i agree with you
i totally agree class sizes are way too
big
this is one of my fundamental complaints
um about the public school system
is that it's a
factory
assembly line
approach to education
and you take hundreds of kids and just
throw them on the assembly line and uh
you turn the lever and they just go down
you know um
they go from from one place to the next
and even if they're not ready to move on
to the next phase in the assembly
process they're going to move on anyway
and because the most important thing is
to spit them out the other end on
schedule
yeah i i i don't like that either
and when you've got like 30 kids in a
classroom or even 20 kids
there's just no way that those kids are
going to get the
individualized personalized attention
that they need
although we have the factory assembly
line approach to education in this
country education is not really
something that can be
done that way
real education has to be personalized
because every person is different and
they all have different brains and
they're on different levels
and they grasp certain subjects a lot
quicker than other subjects and so
in an ideal scenario we would be able to
this is what homeschooling is all about
you come up with a curriculum and an
approach that works for the kid
um
so yeah all that i'm with you
except that the public school
system steadfastly resists any effort to
actually address the class size problem
because how do you end up with smaller
class sizes let's do a little bit of
math if you're a public school teacher
you've got you've got
class sizes that are too big
what does that tell you
it tells you there's too many kids in
the school
so how do we solve that problem by
having fewer kids in the school
and how do we do that school choice
um
homeschooling like actually promoting
homeschooling as a valid option
for parents to explore
that's how you reduce the size of the
classroom
and then you have many fewer kids in the
class and you can and you have some hope
of giving them something
close to a personalized education at
least you can personalize a lot more
than you can now when you've got 30 kids
in the classroom
but you know the woman in the video
there i don't know anything about her
i'm going
but but i do know she's a seattle public
school teacher so i'm going to assume
now wild speculation here she is not a
homeschool advocate and she's not a
school choice advocate
so you want to reduce the size of the
classroom but you resist anything that
would actually accomplish that goal and
accomplish it quickly
and cheaply and efficiently
why because it's not about the size of
the class it's about money
it's about power and it's also that
you're just lazy and you don't want to
work that's what a lot of this is about
and we gotta you know let's be honest
about it like i said
all right
what we got next here so this is from
fox it says more migrants arrived in
chicago from texas on sunday and
democrat mayor lori lightfoot once again
slammed republican texas governor greg
abbott saying he's using them as human
pawns the migrants arrived in the windy
city after abbott sent two buses
carrying migrants to chicago last week
abbott said uh he'll continue to bus
migrants to sanctuary cities until the
federal government secures the southern
border lightfoot said that while she
welcomes new residents she has a problem
with abbott busing the migrants to her
city
she said at a press conference my
frustration comes from the actions of
the governor of texas there could be a
level of coordination cooperation but he
chooses to do none of those things
instead he chooses to send human beings
across the country to an uncertain
destination that's unacceptable
yeah unacceptable to you know allow
human beings to go across the country to
an uncertain destination
unacceptable well once again i agree
with her there here's more of a lori
lightfoot on this issue
governor abbott's racist
and xenophobic practices of expulsion
have only amplified the challenges many
of these migrants have experienced on
their journey to find a safe place the
governor's actions are not just inhumane
they are unpatriotic he is a man without
any morals
humanity
or shame
uh i got to say greg abbott credit where
credit's due i've been critical of
governor abbott in texas
you know uh for
different reasons over the years
but what he's doing here is i mean it's
one of the most brilliant
things that we've seen a republican
governor do
and it's brilliant in its simplicity
and he's put these democrat
you know it and it also it's not just a
like a a a political ploy it's not it's
not just political gamesmanship it is
that too and it's very it's very
effective
strategy as far as that goes but it also
solves a problem for him
we've got all these illegal immigrants
we got the federal government
not securing the border trying to stop
us from deporting them and so instead
all right fine we'll just send it we'll
send them to the states that claim that
they want them
run by governors who are constantly
saying all these wonderful things about
open borders that we should accept
right quoting the inscription on the
statue of liberty about accepting uh
people from all across the world the you
know the weary and the tired and all the
rest of it
well they say that so let's just okay
here you go
and it puts them in this position where
they where they look absolutely absurd
they they are the democrat governors
are being given the opportunity to put
their money where their mouth is and
they're practically in tears about it
this is racist and xenophobic it's
racist
how is it racist
you say you want
illegals in the country so where here
you go
i don't know well no because you want
them yeah you want them coming in but
you don't want them you don't want them
with you
you want it to be tex
texas's problem you know you want them
down on the on the border states you
want them in the red states
and why do you
why is that because this is another
unspeakable thing right but
why do they so they they want
the illegal immigrants to come into the
country
they don't want to secure the border
that's wrong we don't build walls right
build bridges not walls we don't have
walls separating us it's a terrible
thing
so you want them to come in
but you don't want them in your state
and you have a blue state you don't want
them there but you want them in the red
state
why is that
i mean it's almost as if you're trying
to import
voters
like you're trying to replace
you're trying to replace
uh republican voters with with democrat
voters
you're trying to replace red states turn
them into blue states
it's almost like there's a replacement
like a
on the on the scale of it you might even
say a great it's like there's a great
replacement habit you might say that
oh no that's racism of xenophobic too
just to talk about it is racist and
xenophobic
and yet these these blue state governors
don't want the illegals in their
backyard
brilliant by uh governor abbott there
all right what else do we got
okay i wanted to mention this
too if i can find it on my
list of stories here it is
killing time
where is it
oh there it is okay this is from the
daily beast it's good that i spent time
really trying to find this story because
this is an important one britney spears
lashed out monday at her son jaden
federline uh who recently criticized her
in an interview and said that he will
see her again when she's better mentally
in an instagram recording the singer
accused jaden 15 and his brother preston
16 of abandoning her saying that they
always ended their visits early and
spent the time together sleeping or
playing piano
speer says it saddens me that not one of
you has valued me as a person she's
talking to her own children here on
social media by the way um said spears
who's been locked in a very public
battle with her parents sister
ex-husband and uh other family members
since she convinced the court to end a
conservatorship that stripped her of her
rights
she says quote i don't believe in god
anymore because of the way my children
and my family have treated me i'm an
atheist y'all
now i mention this because i i vaguely
sort of followed the britney spears saga
and not because i'm interested in
britney spears but because i'm
interested in what all of this says
about people in general
and it says a lot about people that
britney spears
can claim that her her entire family
including her children are victimizing
her
this is what she's claiming everyone
around her it's like every week there's
another headline of another member of
britney spears's family or friend or
something that's she's she's attacking
and the media is attacking too how dare
you be so mean to poor britney
the media eats it up the public buys it
seems like
and does this even though it's extremely
clear
that she's a mentally unstable
narcissist and she's the common
denominator in all of these situations
so this is the fascinating thing to me
when i see all these people who
buy into the britney spears story she's
a victim and all the rest of it well
have you people not met people
i don't understand this is what boggles
my mind is is when you when you
come across
people
who don't seem to know how people work
like but you are a person
and so
as a person having like lived a human
life have you not
noticed that
every single time
when there's when there's someone who
who claims that everyone around them is
victimizing them and is horrible and
mean and oppressing them in every single
case it turns out that that person is
the problem
if you can't maintain a relationship
with anyone in your life including your
own children
you got to start looking for the common
denominator which is you
now look there are exceptions to every
rule so maybe there's an exception here
there might be a few people out there
who go around claiming that that
everyone's out to get them and that
they're oppressed by everyone and their
whole family and ever and it's actually
true like there may be cases like that
maybe in theory but
if you don't know much about the
situation and we don't know much about
the situation here because we don't know
any of these people all you read is the
headlines
and so you have to make assumptions
based on
what you know about how people work
and the safest assumption here is that
she's just like this miserable
narcissistic
frankly pretty horrible person
not much of an assumption either because
when you're when you're calling out your
own minor children on social media
that alone pretty good indication that
there are problems and uh and the
problems are mainly with you
now i say all this but but i'm starting
to realize maybe one of the part of the
problem here is that
those people who are constantly claiming
that everyone around them is is out to
get them
like they don't realize
that they are that sort of person so
maybe all the people that are rallying
around britney spears they are also that
sort of person
they also think that everyone in their
life is out to get them and all the
problems they have in their many
relationships all the many problems they
have in all of their relationships are
always the fault of the other person
never them
maybe that explains it i don't know it's
possible
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
uh first of all i want to say just to
address one thing
there's been a lot of consternation
perhaps even anguish
maybe i could say over my change of
wardrobe recently
and uh there have been accusations that
i sold out by putting on a sports jacket
because the bar for selling out where
i'm concerned is is extremely low i'm
not given a lot of room here all i have
to do is shower and like comb my hair
and dress business casual people start
acting like i'm driving a lamborghini
and you know i have a butler and i drink
caviar smoothies for breakfast or
something
um and i have to be honest when i when i
that at first when the spg started
complaining about
the move away from the flannels
i was defensive
and i said my body my choice all right
okay don't don't try to control me
how dare you
tell me what to wear i'm a strong
independent woman damn it
but now
i i've seen just how seriously you guys
take that i and i see this like one of
our dw super fans no super nose on
twitter started a poll yesterday on
twitter on the subject of my wardrobe
should i wear blazers or flannels i i
did not ask for this poll i i didn't
actually put it up for a vote but it's
been put up for a vote anyway
and i just looked at it the poll has
over 5 000 responses
and 70 of the respondents are demanding
a return
of the flannels
and i will say again my wardrobe not up
for a vote
unless the results are really lopsided
in which case i'll you know i don't want
to make everyone that mad i'm a man of
principle so i have i've taken it into
advisement that's all i'll say i hear i
hear the outcry of the people i hear it
i hear you
i understand you
and that that's where we'll leave it for
now
um
sierra says i really pride myself on the
fact that at the end of every one of
matt's opening monologues i can
perfectly time his now let's get to our
five headlines and recite it along with
him nailing his inflection you're saying
that i'm predictable
that's an insult you're banned from the
show
luke hanson says hey matt i'm one of the
byu students that co-wrote the byu story
you would unfortunately not be surprised
that many people were scared to talk to
us just to give a statement that they
did not hear anything at the game some
were willing to give statements and
we're told by either a lawyer parent or
coach not to be involved well it's good
that you guys are chasing down the story
you should you know continue to do that
um but really even if nobody talked to
you
that actually tells us all that we need
to know
it's like the silence in this case
answers the question because
certainly if anyone actually did hear
the n-word being shouted at this game
which is what was claimed if anyone
actually heard it they would be
eager to come out and say so
because they'd be greeted as a as a hero
by the media they they'd be on espn and
everything so um the fact that nobody
has come out and said i heard that
tells us that it that it didn't happen
because if it was being shouted as was
originally originally remember it was
claimed that the the n-word was being
shouted
at the black volleyball uh player
not not once but throughout the match
constantly being shouted and nobody
heard it well
that's it
um
simon says
fifo thumb after all these years i just
realized that the giant was probably
just telling jack his pronouns
it is a terrible joke
really bad
and i and i
and i liked it thank you
um
sally says uh i'm always on your side
when it comes to nonsense but not when
it comes to abortion a woman can decide
by herself
so you're always on my side when it
comes to nonsense
except apparently when it comes to the
nonsense that you just said in the very
next sentence
a woman can decide by herself well i
know that a woman
physically can decide that
to kill her child that's i'm fully aware
of that
women and men
after a child is born can also
physically kill their children and many
have
so i'm aware that that's a
a decision that can be made
the question is whether it's the right
decision
that's is it the right thing to do to
kill your child
and i assume that you would say in the
case of a child born outside of the womb
that's that's born is outside the room
that the answer is no and so what you
have to
reflect on is whether that no should
still hold in the womb and if not why
not
and also i always find it interesting
when i hear from people who say well
matt i agree with you on everything
except this one fundamental issue
uh where we're on opposite sides
now that's fine we don't have to agree
on every single issue okay i'm not
saying you have to agree with me on
everything
but
you know my
i i have kind of a world view that's
coherent and and i don't decide my
stance on issues at random
like i have certain underlying
fundamental beliefs and one of them is
about the inherent value and dignity of
human beings
and that underlying belief informs
everything that i say about every social
and political issue
so i'm not even sure if you reject my
underlying belief in the inherent value
and dignity of human beings which you
must reject it if you disagree with me
on abortion then how can you agree with
me on everything else
because
for me everything else grows from that
root
the value and dignity of human life
so what
what are you rooted in what's what's
your fundamental belief
something to think about
um
and finally whiskey tango says the
solution to a lost sock problem is just
have all of your socks look the same i'm
not saying you're limited to one design
or color but the more variables can just
add more problems now you're trying to
control what socks i wear too like can i
can i where can i decide on anything for
myself
trying to take my autonomy from me even
when it comes to my socks just back off
all right
are you still
giving your money to woke razor
companies that hate your values see
masculinity as toxic and think that you
should teach your daughter to shave her
beard
uh i mean if she does have a beard then
she probably should shave it but
anyway
there is a better way jeremy's razors
are 100 real and 100 woke free the
premium matte tungsten handle has more
heft than the left the razer head pivots
without caving and has six blades that
are sharper than truth those other razer
companies keep virtue signaling to the
totalitarian left and using your money
to do it but you don't have to let them
when you buy jeremy's razors you aren't
just making jeremy richer you're making
the woke left poorer which is the most
important thing 75 000 people have
already made the switch you can to visit
jeremysrazers.com to get your founder
series shave kit today that's jeremy's
razors.com
jeremy's razors shut up and shave now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well today we cancel men's health
magazine which is a publication
at this point as concerned with helping
men be healthy as say planned parenthood
is with planning parenthood but perhaps
the better comparison is with the
magazine scientific american which as we
saw a couple weeks ago has completely
abandoned science and replaced it with
delusional lgbt propaganda men's health
has undergone a similar process of
devolution as evidenced by its advice
column sexplanet written by a guy named
zachary zane now zack
whose picture we'll put up on the screen
for reference
describes himself in his bio as
a sex writer author and ethical boy [ __ ]
now zach had to add the word ethical
there because he had decided that the
term boy [ __ ] was somehow not stupid and
embarrassing enough on its own
this is of course the one skill that
most leftists still possess
they are always finding increasingly
inane ways describing themselves
and just when you think that they've
come up with with a label so bizarre in
asinine that it could not possibly be
topped
they come along and drop ethical boy
[ __ ]
so zach goes on explaining that um
in his bio he says over the years i've
had my fair share of sexual experiences
dating and sleeping with hundreds of
people of all genders and orientations
in doing so i've learned a thing or two
about navigating issues in the bedroom
and a bunch of other places tbh i'm here
to answer your most pressing sex
questions with thorough actionable
advice
there's no doubt of course that he has
learned how to navigate certain issues
in the bedroom for example i'm sure you
could tell us which topical ointment is
best for treating monkey pox sores but
outside of managing the side effects of
the many dozens of diseases this man has
most likely contracted over the years
it's not clear what advice he really has
to offer
or what anyone would uh why anybody
would try to solicit in the first place
and yet some people do allegedly like
the guy who sent in
this question for the most recent
edition of his sexplana column
so someone going by the by the moniker
labels are hard writes quote
dear sexplanted if i'm sexually
attracted to people afab which stands
for assigned female at birth because of
anatomy does that make me pan-sexual my
whole life i've identified as a straight
man because i'm sexually attracted to
women's bodies but if i'm attracted to
someone afab who goes who comes out as a
trans man but doesn't choose surgery
does that make me pan or buy i'm not
attracted to people amab
assigned male birth but i am certain
that uh tran but i am to certain trans
men and nbs
which means non-binary by the way if i
change my sexual orientation i feel bad
as if i'm just pretending so i can
encompass their gender identity to be
with them
now before we get to zach's answer
it's worth noting that the person who
wrote this question
just a small detail here almost
certainly doesn't exist
and i know that because advice
columnists frequently invent questions
and also because
no straight man in the world
feels guilty about being straight first
of all as this person seems to nor would
any straight man feel that his
orientation and sexual behavior requires
the blessing of a gay guy in a mesh
t-shirt
there is just
no heterosexual in existence
who's ever said to himself you know i
think it's okay that i'm attracted to
the female form but i better check with
an ethical boy [ __ ] first
no this is a question that mr zane has
come up with
because he has some thoroughly
unsolicited advice that he wants to
offer on the subject and here's what he
says
quote
your attractions technically meet the
definition of bisexuality since you're
attracted to vulva owners of multiple
genders but i don't think you're really
struggling with how you personally
identify it sounds like you know you
might be fetishizing people with a vulva
and you're wondering how to do that
without offending people especially
potential partners who are trans or
non-binary good
this is something you should care about
did you get that if you're attracted to
somebody
if you're attracted to one sex
then you're bisexual
one has become two
bad news for all the circus performers
who have been training on the unicycle
their whole lives it was all a waste of
time because every unicycle is now a
bicycle
words have no meaning
numbers have no meaning
zach continues there's nothing wrong
with having a fetish for a certain body
part i for example have a fetish for
huge asses but it's offensive to reduce
a person to that soul body part in this
case their vulva unless the person is
especially explicitly open to being
fetishized in that way i love when i
find a person who wants me to worship
their ass or wants me to use them
because as the gay boys say i'm just a
whole sir
the real key key here isn't picking the
right label for your orientation if you
list yourself with bi and start matching
with trans men and envies you can't go
around asking them if they have a penis
or a vulva down there that's not only
rude but also potentially triggering for
people with gender gender and body
dysmorphia so go ahead and call yourself
bisexual to expand your pool of
potential partners but you must also
make it crystal clear in your dating app
bio that you're only looking for people
with a vulva this way you know the
people who swipe right on you are
clearly okay with your preferences and
the people who aren't can safely swipe
left i hope you find someone who gets
justice turned on by you reducing them
to their vulva but i'll be real with you
the majority of people cis and trans
aren't down to be fetishized
your search will be slow going but at
least you won't have to feel bad about
pretending anymore
so to review
people attracted to one sex are bisexual
women are mere vulva owners
homosexual heterosexuality rather is a
potentially offensive fetish
and straight men are ethically bound to
announce themselves because there are
some people who may not be okay with
that preference
this is also demented and ridiculous
that it may seem unworthy of any
response at all and perhaps it is but on
the other hand conservatives have made
the mistake of not responding to lots of
demented things over the years until one
day they realize that they probably
should have offered some sort of
response earlier and now it's too late
so on that note i will make a couple of
observations here
first
we see here again the resentment and
hatred that the lgbt left has for women
never mind the phrase volva owner
doesn't even make sense
because your body parts are not objects
that you own
okay
they are the things that physically
comprise you
they're part of you
they are you
right like my hand is not it's not just
this this thing that i went and bought
at a store
hey uh if you cut my hand off i wouldn't
say hey no don't take that i own that
well that's that's me that's my body
that's that's who i am
now the greater point here is that they
insist that women shouldn't be reduced
to their genitals even as they do
exactly that
as always they're the ones doing the
thing they accuse everyone else of doing
projection that's all they do
so the boy [ __ ] here says that if a man
is attracted to women
he must be attracted solely for her
genitals and that's because zach himself
sees women as nothing but genitals like
with a body and brain attached
but in reality a man is attracted to a
female's body
that's true and it's a good thing that
he is because without that attraction
the human species wouldn't exist
a zac himself would not exist if it
wasn't for a long line of men before him
who were according to him volva fetishes
but that's not the full story
a man is is attracted to a female's body
but is also attracted to everything else
about her
right her personality just the way she
is the way she carries herself the way
she speaks the way she sounds
the totality of her of her feminine
presence
we see women as much more than
reproductive organs and we are drawn in
by the whole experience the whole
package
the lgbt left on the other hand denies
that there is anything more to a woman
than her genitals and then says that
even the genitals don't matter
and they do all of this simply so that
men can partake in and appropriate
womanhood
they reduce women
and ultimately erase them
and then accuse us of doing exactly what
they have just done themselves
second um get ready get ready here for
another shift right because living in a
society run by the left means that
you're you're standing on cultural
tectonic plates that are constantly
moving around
shifting jostling often creating huge
earthquakes that can all at once
completely change the landscape
so here it is happening again
for decades
the left worked to remove
the stigma from fetishes and normalize
all uh sexual proclivities and
preferences
they said that nobody should feel
ashamed of who they love or who they're
attracted to
and they largely succeeded in this
project and created exactly the sort of
profligate shameless society they wanted
but now they've changed their minds
because now they say actually a fetish
is shameful and unnatural it turns out
that not all sexual proclivities are
acceptable it's just that
heterosexuality that is the preference
quote unquote that sustains human life
and upon which human civilization
depends
is the shameful unacceptable fetish
victorian prudishness is rapidly coming
back into style except in this kind of
deranged demonic form
it is exactly what is natural and
healthy and life-sustaining which is now
stigmatized
they insisted that the doors be flung
open in the name of inclusion
and they got their way and they were
invited inside
and then they immediately proceeded to
kick everybody else out
and shut and lock the very doors that
they were just demanding be opened
inclusiveness is the ultimate trojan
horse
if only everybody else would stop
falling for it
and also stop reading men's health
magazine
if anyone actually does read it which i
kind of doubt but at any rate it is
today cancelled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show is move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not
godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you